Talk to your doctor about XARELTO®.
There’s more to know.
>> Jason: CLINT EASTWOOD’S
NEWEST FILM IS DEFYING ALL
CONVENTIONAL MOVIE MAKING NORMS
BY USING REAL-LIFE HEROES TO
PLAY THEMSELVES.
TWO AMERICANS WHO STOPPED AN
ISIS ATTACK IN FRANCE IN 2015.
WE SPOKE WITH THE STARS OF
15:17 TO PARIS.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS
EXPERIENCE.
IT MADE INTERNATIONAL HEADLINES.
IT THREW YOU ALL INTO THE
WORLD’S CONSCIOUSNESS.
YOU AND YOUR FRIENDS ARE ON
THIS TRAIN.
THEY ARE SLEEPING.
BUT YOU ARE AWAKE.
WHAT DID YOU HEAR AND WHAT MADE
YOU TAKE ACTION AND WAKE THEM
UP?
>> I WAS HANGING OUT TEXTING
FRIENDS BACK HOME AND TWO
HOURS, THREE HOURS INTO THE
TRIP A HEARD A GUNSHOT AND
BREAKING GLASS.
I KIND OF PUT MY HEAD UP.
I WASN’T SURE IF THAT’S WHAT I
HEARD OR NOT.
I COULDN’T EXACTLY DEFINE IT AT
THE TIME.
AND WHILE I WAS THINKING ABOUT
THAT THE TRAIN RAN KIND OF PAST
US, AWAY FROM THE NOISE AND SO
THAT WOKE THEM UP AND WE LOOKED
BACK TO SEE WHAT HE WAS RUNNING
FROM.
A SHIRTLESS MAN WITH AN AK47.
WE GOT BEHIND THE SEATS.
SPENCER, GET HIM AND HE TOOK
OFF.
SPENCER, YOU TAKE OFF DOWN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS TRAIN.
WHAT MADE YOU RUN AT HIM?
>> IT WAS JUST -- WE JUST
WANTED THE LIVE AND PURE
SURVIVAL.
I CAUGHT A MOMENT DOWN THE
AISLE WHERE I SAW HIM MAYBE
EITHER JAM THE GUN OR MAYBE THE
SAFETY WAS ON.
ALL I KNEW HE HADN’T STARTED
SHOOTING YET.
I JUST SAW IT AS A WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY.
IT IS EITHER NOW OR NEVER.
WE ARE GOING TO DIE EITHER WAY.
>> MY MOTIVATOR WAS THEM BEING
LIFE LONG FRIENDS OF MINE THAT
IT SHUT DOWN MY BRAIN PROCESS
AND IT WAS LIKE ONCE THEY JUMP
INTO ACTION I HAD TO GO HELP AT
THAT POINT.
IT WAS ALL IN OR NOTHING TYPE
SITUATION.
>> SPENCER, YOU GRABBED THIS
GUY, A MEMBER OF AN ISIS CELL
WITH AN IK47.
THAT IS NOT ALL HE HAD.
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN YOU TACKLED
HIM?
>> I WAS TRYING TO GRAB THE AK
FROM HIM A LITTLE BIT AND
PRACTICING JUJITSU AT THE TIME.
WE BOTH STOOD UP AND PUT HIM IN
A CHOKE AND SLAMMED MYSELF
AGAINST A WINDOW.
POINT AND PULLED OUT A PISTOL.
HE TRIES TO SHOOT ME WITH THAT.
THERE WAS NO AMMUNITION KNIT.
ALEC RUNS UP.
GETS THE PISTOL.
AS SOON AS THAT PISTOL GETS OUT
OF HIS HAND HE GRABS A BOX
CUTTER AND STARTS CUTTING THE
BACK OF MY NECK TRYING TO SLIT
MY THROAT AND COMES ACROSS AND
SLICES MY LEFT THUMB TO THE
BONE AND SERVERS MY TENDON AND
NERVE.
I SAW THE KNIFE AND HIM
FLAILING AROUND.
I SCREAMED HE HAS A KNIFE AND
KICKED HIM OFF ME AND WE ALL
PUNCHED AND KICKED HIM AND THE
FIGHT WENT ON.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE, ALEC, THERE
WAS A DIVINE HAND IN ALL OF
THIS IN THE WAY THE EVENTS
TRANSPIRED?
>> IF YOU ADD UP THE ODDS OF US
BEING IN THE TIME AND PLACE AND
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT PUT US
THERE AND WENT TOWARDS US
SURVIVING IT, THAT WILL BE IN
THE MOVIE, TOO.
BUT IT IS JUST TO ME TOO
ASTRONOMICAL TO BE COINCIDENCE.
>> IF ALL THIS WASN’T
TERRIFYING ENOUGH, ANTHONY, YOU
ALL DECIDE WE ARE GOING TO
APPROACH CLINT EASTWOOD WITH
OUR BOOK AND STORY.
HE DECIDES TO DO THIS FILM AND
CASTS YOU ALL AS YOURSELVES.
THIS HAD TO BE A LITTLE
INTIMIDATING HAVING NEVER ACTED
BEFORE.
YOU DIDN’T DO THEATER.
>> NEVER A SCHOOL PLAY OR
NOTHING.
IF HE PICKED UP THE PICTURE HE
WANTS TO DO OUR STORY, WE
THOUGHT THAT WAS GREAT.
THREE WEEKS BEFORE WE START
SHOOTING WE THOUGHT WE WERE
MEETING THE ACTORS PLAYING US
AND HE IS LIKE DO YOU MIND
REENACTING THINGS FOR US ON
CAMERA.
HE SAYS IT AGAIN AND HE SAID
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
YOU SOUND LIKE YOU ARE ASKING
US TO BE IN THE MOVIE.
SURE, WHY NOT.
WHY DON’T YOU JUST DO IT?
>> YOU SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH
HIM ON THE SET.
>> WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH
HIM ON SET.
HE WORKED LONGER DAYS THAN WE
DID AND WE SPENT TIME WITH HIM
HANGING OUT GETTING FOOD,
GETTING DRINKS.
WE EVEN WOULD WORK OUT WITH HIM
FROM TIME TO TIME.
THAT’S ONE OF MY FAVORITE
MEMORIES OF HIM.
SPENCER AND I WERE TALKING
SMACK TO EACH OTHER ABOUT HOW
MANY DIPS WE DO COULD DO AND
CLINT COMES IN THAT’S NOTHING.
WHEN I WAS 75 I COULD DO 25
DIPS.
WE’RE LIKE ALL RIGHT.
LET’S SEE WHAT YOU HAVE NOW.
HE IS 87.
HE HOPS UP ON THE DIP BAR AND
KNOCKS OUT 10 BODY WEIGHT DIPS
LIKE NOTHING.